Mary here with a game spot news updates
now if you're getting sick of seeing
remasters for ps4 and xbox one tough Shh
removes turns a remastered Sleeping Dogs
is coming out for current-gen this
October the game's existence was leaked
by amazon and we know several details
about the re-release will be known as
Sleeping Dogs definitive edition and
will include all the downloadable
content from the original version of the
game naturally we expect it to look
nicer than the 360 and ps3 versions of
the game although it's unclear if it'll
be improved graphically over the already
gorgeous PC release the Amazon page
shows a 59 99 limited edition version
that will be released october fourteenth
and comes with a 28-page book of concept
art this game is awesome and if you
haven't already played it you should try
it but it's up to you if you want to buy
it for around ten bucks on PC or last
gen or you want to spend 60 for the
current-gen Levi Harris said cool but
I'd rather see a sequel what do you guys
think leave your comments down below and
for more rerelease news which there will
be more of head to gamespot com so a
really gained 60 bucks
you